hi everyone
this is professor m da science and today
i'm going to talk about angular momentum
eigenvalues in another one of our videos
on rigorous quantum mechanics
angular momentum is a key property in
classical mechanics where the orbital
angular momentum
is central in many problems if anything
angular momentum is actually even more
important
in quantum mechanics where we not only
have the orbital variant but we also
have
spin angular momentum which does not
have a classical analog
this means that in quantum mechanics you
will come across angular momentum
eigenvalues
all the time there is a companion video
linked in the description
where we derive angular momentum
eigenvalues mathematically
showing that they are quantized what i
want to do in this video is to discuss
the language that is typically used
when discussing angular momentum
eigenvalues among other things we will
discuss some widely used but actually
somewhat confusing conventions
we will look at a few examples of
allowed angular momentum
and we will also anticipate some of the
key differences between orbital and spin
angular momentum
so let's go as always let's start with
the summary of angular momentum in
quantum mechanics
we consider a vector operator j made of
three operators j1 j2 and j3
this operator j will be an angular
momentum operator if the three
components obey
these commutation relations and here i'm
using the
levy chevita symbol and the convention
that we sum
over repeated indices k if these ideas
don't sound familiar to you
then you should first check out the
video that introduces angular momentum
j is a general angular momentum and it
includes the orbital angular momentum
that we're familiar with from classical
mechanics
and that we typically label with the
letter l
and it also includes a spin angular
momentum that doesn't have a classical
analog and for which we use the letter
s as we can see
up here the different angular momentum
components don't commute
which implies that they don't form a set
of compatible observables
but we know from the video on angular
momentum that we can define
another operator j squared equal to j1
squared plus j2 squared plus j3 squared
that does commute with each individual
component
this means that in the quantum theory of
angular momentum
we can build a set of compatible
observables by considering j
squared and one of the components ji and
we conventionally use j3
we now build the theory of angular
momentum in quantum mechanics with these
two compatible observables j
squared and j3 the key equations
are the eigenvalue equations which for j
squared takes this form where the
eigenvalue is lambda
and for j3 we have this eigenvalue
equation
where the eigenvalue is mu
these eigenstates here and here are a
common set of eigenstates for the two
commuting observables
and i label them with the eigenvalues
lambda and mu
so that this is clear in the confining
video on angular momentum eigenvalues
we found out that the eigenvalues lambda
and mu
cannot take just any arbitrary value but
instead can only take a set of special
values
lambda is always given by j j plus one h
bar squared
where j can only take the values zero
one half one three halves two
five halves three and so on in steps of
one half
the values zero one two three and so on
are obviously
integers and we call the values one half
three halves five halves and so on
half integers half integer simply means
that we pick
an odd integer and divided by two
once we have determined the value of j
from this list
then mu is always given by this form
m h bar and m can only take
the values minus j minus j plus one
minus j plus two and so on in steps of
one
all the way to j minus one and finally
j and this list here contains
two j plus one possible values for him
so this is it for the angular momentum
eigenvalues
in the companion video i go into a lot
of detail over the mathematical
derivation as to why
these are the only allowed eigenvalues
of j squared and j3
today's video you'll be happy to hear is
much lighter on the maths front
and i instead focus on some important
concepts that we need to be familiar
with
relating to these eigenvalues
so let's start with a sanity check and
just confirm that these eigenvalues have
the correct units for an angular
momentum
the key insight is to realize that
planck's constant
and similarly the reduced planck
constant
both have units of angular momentum
planck's constant is a fundamental
physical constant
which since 2019 is actually defined
to have the exact value h equals
6.62607015
times 10 to the minus 34 joules
times second in si units
historically planck's constant was the
proportionality constant between
the energy and the frequency of a
quantum of light
called a photon you can straight away
check that the units of energy
being joules and those of frequency
being inverse seconds
leads to the units of h being joules
times second
so what is the dimension of the planck's
constant then it is basically equal to
energy times time
there are various ways in which we can
spell out energy so let's just
pick the infinitesimal work done by
displacing a particle
using a force f by some infinitesimal
distance
dr this means that the dimension of
energy
is force times length
and in turn using newton's second law
we get that force is equal to mass times
acceleration so that the dimension of
force is equal to
mass times length divided by time
squared
putting everything together we get that
the dimension of planck's constant is
equal to
mass times length squared divided by
time
if we now write the familiar formula for
orbital angular momentum
l as r cross p then
we have that the dimension of r is
length
and the dimension of momentum is mass
times length divided by time
so overall we get that the dimension of
angular momentum
is mass times length squared divided by
time
comparing the dimension of planck's
constant with the dimension of angular
momentum we see that they
are indeed the same therefore the fact
that the eigenvalue of j
squared is proportional to h bar squared
is consistent with j
squared being the square of an angular
momentum
and similarly the fact that the
eigenvalue of j 3
is proportional to h bar is also
consistent
with j 3 being an angular momentum
component
the next topic i want to discuss relates
to conventions
about notation we started with these
general eigenvalue equations for j
squared and for j3 with the
corresponding eigenvalues lambda
and mu but now that we know that lambda
can only take these values
with j in turn given by this
and that mu can only take these values
where
m is given by this
it then makes sense to replace all
lambdas and mu's
by their allowed values in particular we
can do this for the common set of
eigenstates
and we could write them like this
however in practice we simplify the
notation and write these eigenstates as
jn in this language the eigenvalue
equation for j squared becomes
this and the eigenvalue equation for
j3 becomes this
another important simplification that is
used when working with angular momentum
is that for a system in eigenstate jn
we typically say that this is a state
with angular momentum
j now this language is used constantly
so it is very important to become
familiar with it
but it is also essential that you don't
forget what an eigenstate jm
really means it means that the j
squared eigenvalue is j times j plus 1
times h bar squared
and that the j 3 eigenvalue is m h bar
we're now ready to look at a few
examples of angular momentum eigenvalues
and eigenstates
let's start by placing the relevant
quantities at the top
starting with j then the j squared
eigenvalue
then m then the j3 eigenvalue and then
the corresponding eigenstate the first
possible j value in the list is j equals
zero
the eigenvalue is trivially zero m is
also zero
and so is the j3 eigenvalue so this is
an easy case
there is a single eigenstate which we
label by zero zero
let's now look at the next possible j
value in the list which is j
equals one half for the j
squared eigenvalue we plug in one half
in the usual expression
which multiplies to three over four h
bar squared
there are now two possible values of m
the first is minus j
so minus one half and the second is plus
j
so plus one half these two
m values give two possible eigenvalues
minus one-half h-bar and plus one-half
h-bar
there are two eigenstates for j equals
one-half which are
one-half minus one-half and one-half
plus one-half we now move on to the next
eigenvalue in the list
we get j equals 1. we can plug in the
value 1 in the j squared
eigenvalue expression and overall we get
2
h bar squared there are now three
possible values for
n the first is minus j so minus one
then we add one to get zero and
we add one again to get plus one and
this is it because plus one is now
already equal to j these three
n values give three possible j three
eigenvalues
minus h bar zero and plus h bar
and looking at the eigenstates we also
have three and they are labeled by
one minus one one zero and one plus one
you can now see how this would continue
for other allowed values of j
and the corresponding m so you should be
able to build basically any combination
that you need
for most of our discussion of angular
momentum we've used a general definition
of angular momentum
however we know that we can be more
specific and discuss the special
case of orbital angular momentum which
is analogous to the corresponding
quantity in classical mechanics
and we also have the spinal momentum
which is a purely quantum mechanical
quantity
we also know that we label a general
angular momentum using the letter j
but that when we want to specify orbital
angular momentum we instead use the
letter
l and for spin angular momentum we use
the letter
s as you can imagine we use similar
changes in annotation when we talk about
eigenvalues and eigenstates
the j squared eigenvalue label small j
is typically replaced by the label small
l
for orbital angular momentum and by the
label small layers
for spin angular momentum the
corresponding
eigenvalues read as usual for the
general case
and then for the orbital they are in
terms of l
and for spin in terms of this
for the j3 eigenvalue label m if there
is no possibility of confusion
then we also typically just use m for
both orbital
and spin angular momentum however if we
have a system in which multiple types of
angular momentum
must be included at the same time then
we can use
m subindex l for orbital
and m sub index s for spin to avoid any
kind of confusion
for the sake of clarity in the rest of
the video i will use
ml and ms but remember that we can have
either option
and it should be clear what is meant by
the context
in this more involved notation the
corresponding eigenvalues read
mh bar mlh bar and msh bar
and finally the eigenstates jm become
lml for orbital and sms for spin
feel free to explore our other videos
for examples of
orbital and spin angular momenta that
you can find
linked in the description
the very final thing i want to do is to
anticipate some of the discussion in the
videos on orbital and spin angular
momentum
let's consider again our eigenvalue
equation for j squared
and for j3 and remember again that small
j
can be zero one half one three halves
two and so on
and that for a given j then m can be
any of the values minus j minus j plus
one
all the way to j in steps of one
we derive these allowed values in the
companion video on angular momentum
eigenvalues
and the only assumption behind that
derivation is
the defining commutation relation of the
angular momentum
operator j that derivation tells us that
these here are the possible values of j
and m
but in fact the derivation does not tell
us that they must all occur
only that they can occur as we discuss
in the corresponding videos
it turns out that when we have orbital
angular momentum
then the only values of j that can occur
are the
integer values so if you use the
notation introduced in the previous
slide
this means that small l can only be 0
1 2 3 and so on in integer steps
and as a consequence ml must also be an
integer
the story is completely different with
spin angular momentum
in this case j can take both integer or
half integer values
perhaps the most important example of
spin angular momentum is that of spin
one half where again using the notation
from the previous slide we have
small s equal to one half and
then ms can be either minus one half or
plus one half
spin one half is central in quantum
mechanics because the electron happens
to be a spin one-half particle
this means that to study anything
ranging from the simplest atom
to the most complex material the theory
of spin one-half angular momentum
is a must in this video
we've done some necessary bookkeeping to
make sure that we have the right
language to work with angular momentum
you're now ready to explore
many topics in which angular momentum is
key from the differences between
orbital and spin angular momenta to the
hydrogen atom
and don't forget to check out the
mathematical derivation of angular
momentum eigenvalues
in the companion video and as always if
you liked the video
please subscribe
you